[Musique]
c'est génial ça chez les flyers une de
mona c'est les flyers et le monde c'est
un petit groupe californien qui vraiment
faisait pas le bruit et ils vont y
changer du jour au lendemain j'adore ça
progresse souffrant au sol à gubbio sont
satisfaits
de leur corps après le confluent morts
et jeté petit en taille et je saigne
aulas a une beaucoup les médias chinois
les polices belge et là je vais tomber
dans les pommes
j'imagine mon père randonne salle de my
way qu'une tondeuse à la main et tu es
mon fils ont tourné la tête et vous avez
écrit à nicolas sarkozy
oui pratiquement pourquoi vous m'avez
écrit parce qu'en fait j'avais pour
ambition d'être dans la police
fauchon s'il ne fait pas dix ans la
durée buvant pas qu'elle dure 2 sophie
auger duré 50 des jeux j'étais pas bien
est ce qu'en fait il faut faire un mètre
soixante pour être dans la police je
suis bon ben moi je devais lui être 12
cm je vous avais la phobie du père
fouras non mais vraiment c'est pas
possible
[Rires]
fou sort au sort au cerveau et en boîte
soro soro au premier soit mais quand les
cheveux et puis je voudrais remercier
tout trouvé voilà tous mes fans tout ce
qui à chaque fois prennent le temps
vraiment de répondre à chacun des
acteurs ils sont exceptionnels voilà
j'en ai plante est un bien sûr items
loïc je veux pas tous les citer voilà
mais il y en a plein et j pop voilà
j'adore aussi j pop us ce qui est
exceptionnel
il y en a plein à elodie voilà tous
[Musique]